parts of Beijing are submerged after
storms brought by typhoon doksuri
hummeled the Chinese capital for four
days
the average rainfall for the month of
July fell here in just 40 hours
triggering flash floods and landslides
evacuation orders were issued for more
than 50 000 people
clean operations are underway in the
worst hit areas of montogo and function
several Vehicles were swept away as
roads were turned into rivers
the flood was scary many cars were
washed away even people were washed away
there's nothing you can do about a
natural disaster
I have never seen such heavy rain in my
life maybe just a few times but this
time the rain lasted for so long
authorities have deployed military
helicopters to deliver supplies to
stranded train passengers three trains
were trapped on their roots and many
roads were blocked thousands of
households have been left without
running water emergency teams have been
dispatched to deliver food and other
supplies
River swell to dangerous levels
prompting use of a flood storage
reservoir for the first time in 25 years
several Subway Lines have been suspended
it's rare for a typhoon to hit Inland
Beijing yet only the second time in
recent history that a red alert was
issued for storms the Deluge followed
weeks of record high temperatures
extreme weather that scientists
attribute to climate change
typhoon doxori swept through the
southern province of fujian on the
weekend affecting more than 2 million
people and causing damage with more than
2 billion dollars eighteen thousand
harms have been destroyed
China is now preparing for another
typhoon kanoon which is approaching the
East Coast katrinau Al Jazeera Beijing